There's a new report that the Trump white
house has been hiding, not
only the transcript with the Ukrainian president's
phone call with Donald Trump, but also transcripts
with Vladimir Putin as well as Saudi Royals,
including the crown Prince Mohammad bin Solomon.
And of course anyone surprised why wouldn't
they, who would believe that the white house
has this entire other computer system for
hiding things?
And the only thing they hid was the transcript
with the Ukrainian president.
Of course they're using it for other things.
And there are new reports which say that the
transcripts from calls with the Russian president,
Vladimir Putin and a number of members of
Saudi Royal family, again including Mohammad
bin Solman are hidden on a separate server.
Where does that ring a bell?
Wasn't it Hillary who had problems with private
servers and improperly handling information.
Another instance of projection from Donald
Trump, and of course we already have the whistleblower
complaining alleging that this was done with
Donald Trump's Ukraine phone call and now
the New York times and CNN had been told by
other sources that actually this is being
done with all sorts of communications.
So this is number one, much worse than just
one phone call.
And then number two, it's also much worse
than just Trump because we are now getting
more and more names of people that are being
pulled into the circle of knowledge as of
who was aware that this was going on.
There are allegations that secretary of state,
Mike palmed PEO, and then national security
advisor, John Bolton, were the only people
in the room for some of these calls which
were then buried.
There are now committees that want a question.
Mike Pompeo and John Bolton, Trump said he
would have the most transparent administration
in history.
The opposite is true, going to new lengths
Nixonian length, even more than Nixonian lengths
to hide transcripts.
The Trump administration has ignored subpoenas
of all sorts of documents meant to increase
transparency.
They were asked for lease agreements from
Trump properties.
They were asked for documents about the transfer
of nuclear technology to Saudi Arabia.
They just ignore all of those requests when
a whistleblower comes forward to try to expose
some of this stuff.
Trump is caught on a recording, which I played
for you last week, hinting that either the
whistleblower or the people or person who
informed the whistleblower should be killed
like we used to do to people who committed
treason.
This is not transparent.
This is transparently corrupt, better said,
and they just don't care.
And if you've been following the administration,
you're not surprised.
At the minutia of it.
But what you really have to understand, you
know, we're, we're, we're starting to think
increasingly in post Trump terms because either
in a year and a half or in five and a half
years, scary to think about Trump's going
to go.
And the long lasting impact will be not only
all of those judges that he will have appointed
by the time he's done, who will control the
judiciary for a very, very long time, uh,
not only the alliances with other countries
are historic democratic allies that Donald
Trump has ruined relationships with.
That will be one of the legacies.
But what Donald Trump has done is so fundamentally
at odds with democracy.
And what you have to understand is that there
is actually, in most democracies even, you
know, liberal democracies, there is a portion
of the population that wants tyranny, or at
least they're open to tyranny rather than
democracy.
As long as they are the ones who get to enforce
it.
And that is maybe the most accurate way to
describe what we have in the Trump administration.
We can point out the individual authoritarian
tendencies.
We can point out Trump being just so smitten
with Duterte and Putin and Kim Jong moon and
you know, the whole list of balsa and narrow,
whoever you want to include, and being increasingly
distant and at odds with just liberal democratic
leaders, Germany, the UK, well not the UK
anymore, now that it's Trump to Boris Johnson,
but you get the idea, we can point that out.
But what underlies this is that we really
have a segment of these right wing authoritarians
that are about tyranny.
As long as it's a tyranny they get to enforce,
and that is extremely, extremely scary.
Uh, and allegedly, and we'll talk about this
next, there are some Republicans who if they
voted on impeachment on a secret ballot, would
be willing to remove Donald Trump.
And that's what I want to talk about next.